if medicine's pinup boy dr anthony fauci
thought today's house hearing would be
another fawn fest
boy was he in for a rude awakening today
saint anthony had to contend with
real yet fairly straightforward
questions from congressman jim
jordan when do americans get their
freedom back when we get the level of
infection
in this country low enough that it is
not
a really high what is low enough give me
a number to get the level of infection
in this country low that it is no longer
a threat that is when don't think
americans liberties have been threatened
last year dr falchi
i don't look at this as a liberty thing
congressman jordan well tell me the
number tell me the number
90 uh the members of congress get
vaccinated but i don't want you to
answer my question the american people
want dr
fauci to answer the question what does
it have to be fire sir
if you need to respect the chair and
shut your mouth
joining me now is the man you just saw
congressman jim jordan from ohio
also with me dr jay bhattacharya
professor of medicine at stanford
congressman let's start with you a
fairly straightforward question
which one we've been asking since last
april give us
the objective metrics when can kids go
back to school we know that's not
dangerous
when can we get our freedom back and
always moving the goal post uh but his
guardians rushed in to defend him didn't
they
yeah but i mean in what world does an
unelected bureaucrat
get to tell american citizens when we
can exercise our god-given liberties
when we can exercise our constitutional
rights our
first amendment rights i mean for a year
now americans have been told you can't
go to church can't go to work can't go
to school
can't go to a loved one's funeral can't
assemble can't for a year now
citizens haven't been able to come to
their capital to lobby
their representative to petition them to
redress their grievances
they can't do that and if you dare speak
out against dr fauci
you get censored you get attacked even
dr batachara knows that he's been
attacked and he's a he's a physician
of a medical school professor from
stanford for goodness sake
even that's not good enough for the for
the radical left so
that's what's driving me crazy and we
just like to know and laura you're right
you were one of the very first to point
this out a year ago
on your show i mean the american people
are tired of this
and just tell us when it's going to end
when we get our rights back
well i guess the american people have to
remember that
the government can't take certain rights
away those are
inalienable rights life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness
endowed by our creator you're exactly
right and and so he doesn't have the
right and frankly the government doesn't
have the right to take a lot of these
basic freedoms away dr bonitar i want to
go to you on this because
we we have keep hearing about the number
of
cases in the community but you see how
he got very nervous when he was
asked for a specific number doctor why
is that
i mean he there's no number other than
zero that would satisfy him i think i
mean that that's
that's the problem um cases are not the
problem cases in the vulnerable
population is the problem
and once we've uh vaccinated the
vulnerable population the older
population
uh we're done with the epidemic you
asked about schools we should open
schools tomorrow there's no excuse not
to have them open immediately
uh you know at the the uh i think we
made a lot of progress already actually
80 percent of
people 65 and up in the us have had at
least the first dose of the vaccine
um dr fauci is probably the number one
anti-vaxxer in the country in some sense
because he has a model behavior that is
that has
made people think the vaccine won't give
you back your life but it will
it's an incredibly effective vaccine um
you know he's wearing a mask he's been
vaccinated
i don't really understand uh what what
he's what he's
what he's trying to do with here and i
completely agree with representative
jordan
that the uh the dr fatchi seems utterly
blind to the collateral damage from the
lockdown including our liberty but also
our our health
other on our other health needs now
congressman jordan later in the hearing
i think a lot of folks missed this
you continued to press dr frauchi on
when we could fully
open the country give us your best guess
then
i just did no you didn't you didn't give
us a time what when do you think this is
good are we going to be doing are we
going to be here
two years from now wearing masks
dr fauci the same question well let me
let me answer your van thing again let
me just
not ranting yes you are
so that was a personal attack uh i mean
well we have
the rose parade in 2025 the super bowl
fully attended in 2026 i mean
congressman jordan he doesn't want to be
specific
ever we p we pay him 400 the taxpayers
of this great country
whose whose liberties have been
infringed and assaulted and attacked for
the last year
paid this individual 417 thousand
dollars a year
the highest paid bureaucrat in the in
the entire federal government
why can't he give us an answer just give
us an answer dr batachary is right let's
get back to
allowing this country to flourish like
it was before this before this virus hit
the country it is
it is so obvious that we need to get
back to normal get back to respecting
the constitution
risk every single right under the first
amendment has been attacked
over the last year and there are all
kinds of other costs as the doctor
pointed out there are social costs there
are health costs there are certainly
economic costs there are all kinds of
costs but they've never
i know this virus is serious but let's
get back to normal
but dr given your professional opinion
with all of the facts that we know and
we have frankly we've known for almost a
year about this virus
it can be deadly in certain uh
circumstances especially with
people with high bmi obesity so forth
but given what we know are these
controls on on personal personal
freedoms
do they seem to be tailored to a concern
about a virus or something different
i mean i don't want to second guess but
i will say that they haven't been
particularly effective at stopping the
virus uh and
and you know florida is relatively open
california's locked down and the and the
age-adjusted death rate is actually
worse in california
they have they we paid this enormous
cost
in terms of these lockdowns in so many
ways
and yet we've gotten very little for it
um the the uh we
have to learn to live with this epidemic
with this virus it's not like it's going
to go away
in in and in fact in many ways we have
with the vaccine
uh we should dr fauci should be touting
the good news about
this and telling the truth which is that
uh we are very very close to being able
to say we're done with the epidemic
we just need to get the vaccines in the
arms and the of the of the vulnerable
and then
encourage that well it's the they want
they want a new normal the old normal
they never liked this
gives them their chance to have a new
normal i'm convinced i've been convinced
for a long time and that's really
what much of this is about gentlemen
thank you